bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo bonjour nomura qui dit
bonjour michael bonjour à tous nous
allons développer toute l'actualité
politique et parlementaire au 45 minutes
et voici l'actualité de cette semaine la
sphère du triple à
la france l'a t-elle véritablement perdu
oui selon l' agence de notation standard
and poor's
non selon moody's c'est à en perdre son
latin les socialistes en tout cas saute
sur l'occasion pour critiquer le bilan
de nicolas sarkozy
c'est dans ce contexte que se tient à
l'elysée le sommet social devenu sommet
de crise
au menu des mesures consensuelles sur le
chômage partiel ou la formation des
chômeurs
nicolas sarkozy est resté discret sur la
question de la tva sociale avec les
syndicats il réserve ses annonces pour
les français ce sera à la fin du mois et
à la télévision
enfin t'expliquerai la polémique au
sénat la loi sur la négation des
génocides saura-t-elle voté lundi
prochain dans l'hémicycle l'assemblée
nationale a déjà adopté la commission
des lois du sénat l'a jugée
inconstitutionnelle et avec nous pour
commenter l'actualité
nicolas dupont aignan bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sur ce gâteau député
non inscrit de l'essonne président du
mouvement debout la république à ce
titre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
où en êtes vous de vos parrainages
aujourd'hui ça avance bien
la grande question les parages je suis
confiant pour autant jeudi au maire
continuer à nous par aînés nous l'ont la
réponse définitive fin février si on a
dépassé les 450 il nous en manque très
peu pour atteindre pour atteindre le
seuil fatidique les aviez pas eu la
salle fois-ci voilà pourquoi lancer est
rassuré les rues dans beaucoup seriez
plus content prudents alors que d'autres
candidats sont très inquiets on pense
notamment à la marine aux peintres
évidemment écoutez moi j'ai fait un tour
de france j'ai beaucoup travaillé mais
équipes ont été sur le terrain on a reçu
un très bon accueil pour autant encore
une fois je dis aux maires et des mois
ce n'est pas encore garanti j'ai besoin
de chaque signature
il ya eu un sondage qui montre est 40%
des français pour vous et pour d'autres
candidats souhaitaient vraiment que vous
ayez vos parrainages l'impression que
les français veulent quand même beaucoup
de candidats au premier tour
ce chiffre de 40% ça vous a fait plaisir
oui mais je crois qu'en fait les
français ont compris que tout était fait
pour maintenir un monopole politique du
parti socialiste et l'ump deux parties
qui ont toutes échoué depuis 30 ans
qu'ils se maintiennent au pouvoir en
vérité que parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'alternative forte et crédible et qui
joue du front national d'ailleurs pour
se maintenir au pouvoir
donc je crois que les français ont très
bien compris qu'il fallait tourner la
page
la question se pose nos compatriotes
c'est de savoir avec qui comment et
c'est pourquoi je suis candidat pour
leur dire qu'il ya une autre voie
possible et les sondages on vous crédite
de 0,5 peut-être à 1%
ça vaut la peine d'aller à l'élection
présidentielle pour faire 0 5 ou
important vous savez les sondages sont
aussi l'instrument de cette domination
des deux parties pour casser à l'avance
toute personnalité nouvelle toute offre
politique nouvelle et il ya un sondage
qui est sûr à 100% 100% c'est que des
sondages se sont toujours trompés hervé
morin s'est rendu à l'edt hervé morin
s'est rendu à l'elysée
pour nicolas sarkozy est ce que vont
vous a demandé de venir est ce que vous
irez chercher si c'est le cas on ne va
pas demander car je crois qu'ils savent
très bien que je ne viendrais pas en
fait je n'aime pas les allers-retours je
ne suis pas un rabatteur de voix n'est
pas été ministre
j'ai quitté l'ump avant l'élection
présidentielle la veille de
l'investiture nicolas sarkozy j'avais
annoncé ce qui se passerait je n'ai
jamais livré d' attaques personnelles
contre le président je n'ai pas écrit
deux livres à charge après avoir été
ministre
je n'aime pas d aller retour je ne fonde
sur les idées sur un projet pour mon
pays qui est différente celui nicolas
sarkozy mais vous avez des relations
avec le président de la république quand
même notre jeune qu aucune mais il sait
que je ne suis pas du genre à avoir
besoin d'une tape dans le dos
d'une décoration ou d'un poste pour
changer d'avis et si vous n'avez pas vos
500 signatures même si ça a l'air bien
parti
les signatures et pour le deuxième tour
dans ce cas là il est onze ingold le
deuxième tour nous le verrons après le
premier là aussi on veut enfermer les
français dans un choix préétabli
un choix destructeur de la nation
moi je propose une autre voie
laissez-moi l'a proposé les français
trancheront et je pense qu'on sera
surpris a commenté l'actualité ans
semblait lundi ce sont les suites de la
déflagration la perte du triple à un
début de semaine aux allures de gueule
de bois après la dégradation par
standard and poor's de la note de la
france l' agence moody's a beau annoncer
dans la matinée qu'elle maintient pour
l'instant la bonne note française rien
n'y fait le moral est au plus bas et
chaque camp politique en profite pour
attaquer johan cela ira à longué bonjour
et merci d'être là le président attaqué
mais chez ministre en première ligne
pour le défendre
éteindre l'incendié de la perte du
triple à pour gérard longuet ce matin
la stratégie passe une nouvelle fois par
l' attaque en règle du candidat
socialiste
les capitaines qui frôle trop les côtes
et qui conduisent leurs bateaux sur les
récifs et je trouve que françois
hollande côtoient et tutoie les déficits
publics avec beaucoup de complaisance
françois hollande comparé au capitaine
du navire de croisière costa une
polémique de trop pour laurent fabius
contre la bêtise bum mais dieu ne
peuvent rien pour qui la perte du triple
a entre autres choses figurera bel et
bien dans le bilan de nicolas sarkozy
nous avons l'endettement sarkozy 600
milliards d'euros d'endettement en plus
nous avons vraisemblablement d'ici
quelques jours la tva
sarkozy et notamment pour couronner le
tout la dégradation sorti une
dégradation synonyme d'embellie pour
tous les candidats de l'opposition bien
sûr hors de question de se réjouir de la
disparition du triple a mais cet après
midi à son tour eva joly y voit la
sanction du dernier quart
non ce qui a été dégradée ce la
politique menée par nicolas sarkozy
et lorsque on sait qu'il a monté en
épingle et l'histoire du 3e type en les
qualifiant de notre trésor national
aujourd'hui il doit aussi en tirer les
conséquences
il n'a pas su avec sa politique empêcher
la dégradation
difficile pour l'instant de prédire
l'impact électoral de cette annonce une
manne politique pour tous les candidats
de gauche qui pourrait également donner
de nouveaux arguments à françois bayrou
et à marine le pen
et puis à l'assemblée nationale le
premier ministre et le secrétaire
général de l'ump jean françois copé au
nom profité pour mener la contre
offensive et s'en prendre à la gauche
qualifiant la réaction de petit tsunami
médiatique écoutez j'ai été comme
beaucoup indigné de voir monsieur
hollande depuis les antilles dans une
salle ivre est à moitié vide
une bonne nouvelle pour lui
nous avons assisté vendredi à une sorte
de petit tsunami médiatique qu'ils
étaient par moments aussi indécent que
déplacer nous ne demandons pas
l'opposition d'approuver nos choix dit
notre bilan nous lui demandons
simplement de ne pas aggraver les
difficultés de notre pays et celle des
dirigeants européens
nicolas n'est point ne alors fait perte
du triple à
oui ou non est ce que c'est en fait là
la dégradation du bilan de nicolas
sarkozy
c'est la dégradation bien sûr de son
bilan car je ne vois pas en quoi il
n'est pas comptable de la situation
budgétaire après cinq ans d'exercice du
pouvoir
pour autant les autres partis qui ont
accepté la politique de l'euro qui ont
accepté le libre échange déloyal qui ont
signé tous les traités européens qui
nous ont mis dans cette situation et qui
ont placé nos entreprises en état de
faiblesse sont autant responsables et ce
qui est surprenant c'est que personne ne
se pose la question de savoir comment on
peut en sortir autrement que par des
coupes budgétaires qui vont alimenter
une récession à la grecque
et c'est ça qui est terrible
on a un gouvernement totalement hors
course dans cette affaire de mauvaise
foi éclatante mais on a une opposition
qui n'a pas la solution
moi je vais proposer des solutions
qu'elles complètent l'une des solutions
proposées aujourd'hui la solution que je
propose c'est de se préoccuper de la
création de richesses en france on peut
c'est un peu comme une voiture
une voiture qui avancerait plus il ya
deux solutions celle que nous propose
l'ump et le ps en fait c'est d'alléger
la voiture leur a supprimé le siège de
rétroviseurs la portière et on sera
tellement mal dans la voiture il est
clair que c'est les souffrances pour les
français et puis à celui comme moi qui
propose de renforcer le moteur
économique parce que vous pouvez réduire
toutes les dépenses
si on continue les délocalisations on
n'en sortira jamais et pour éviter les
délocalisations
il faut sortir de l'euro au plus vite
pour alléger le prix la monnaie et il
faut il faut aussi le mettre en place un
vrai protectionnisme intelligent comme
font tous les pays sérieux dans le monde
qui permettent de lutter contre la
concurrence déloyale l'esclavagisme qui
va ruiner toutes nos entre sortir de
l'euro aujourd'hui ça paraît presque de
la folie que si on voit par exemple les
autres pays comment on fait par rapport
au commerce extérieur le commerce
intérieur c'est inéluctable d'abord
c'est très proche et c'est au contraire
la seule solution raisonnable et en
sortir seuls de l'euro mais sans on va
surfer plusieurs puisque très vite
la grèce va sortir l'italie va sortir le
portugal l'espagne c'est une question de
mois ou d'années pour une raison très
simple c'est qu'on ne peut pas vivre
dans un pays dans une économie asphyxiée
par une monnaie trop cher tous les
exportateurs tous ceux qui sont sur le
terrain de l'entreprise oi bien que vous
pouvez réduire les charges de 2%
si vous avez une monnaie comme l'euro
surévalué de 20 ou de 30 c'est tous les
marchés qui tombent et les
délocalisations les délocalisations
souvent pour cause l'euro trop cher et
puis vous me dites ça serait la
catastrophe mais moi je vous pose une
question par rapport aux autres pays
mais l'allemagne notamment comment la
souhaite vie comment le danemark vie
comment la pologne vit
tous ces pays qui ont 4 % de croissance
4 % de croissance en souhaite cette
année
la pologne qui a eu la chance de ne pas
avoir une monnaie trop cher ces pays
sont en dehors de l'union européenne ces
pays sont fascistes
ces pays ont des barbelés autour d'eux
non ils vivent très bien modèle
économique différent et bien oui et
c'est parce qu'on a abandonné notre
modèle à nous de croissance aux consorts
de nourrir le protectionnisme nos
enfants parce qu on laisse nos familles
crever parce que on a nos industries qui
ferment les unes après les autres que
notre pays va mal
donc si on veut réduire la dette oui il
faut faire cesser les gaspillages donc
voyez tour of mais il faut aussi
relancer la machine économique et donc
il faudra moi je propose une solution
que je crois sérieuse qui est leur
offrant c'est à dire une monnaie commune
on passerait de la monnaie unique à la
monnaie commune
c'est inéluctable toute façon ça se fera
le tout c'est de le faire rapidement
dans le calme pour maintenir une
coopération européenne intelligente pour
garder un échange avec nos partenaires
mais donner à nos entreprises de l'air
pour exporter c'est ça l'enjeu majeur
alors on passe au mardi gandrange
passage obligé de tous les candidats
en 2008 nicolas sarkozy avait promis aux
salariés d'arcelormittal à gandrange de
venir à leur secours
quelques mois plus tard une partie de
l'usiné fermait depuis le site
sidérurgique est devenu une sorte de
pèlerinage en hommage aux fausses
promesses du président sarkozy en ce
mardi les ouvriers ou a donc arrivée
françois hollande c'est un sujet de
chloé buffard et jean baptiste daoulas
l'image se veut symbolique martine aubry
françois hollande ensemble pour visiter
une des dernières à siri de lorraine
deux anciens rivaux deux alliés de
raisons pour dénoncer la politique de
nicolas sarkozy et de vous le dire à une
personne qui l'a payé ici dans cette
entreprise s'est tourné vers elle et lui
a dit merci pour l'époque son père en
fait nous sommes ici pour dire que
l'emploi a été oubliée par le
gouvernement la politique industrielle
et que françois hollande est celui qui
porte le chemin de ce redressement
productif industriels le candidat
socialiste ensuite rencontré les
syndicats d'arcelormittal
une entreprise que nicolas sarkozy avait
promis d'aider en 2009 et qui a
finalement fermé difficile pour ces
salariés de croire encore aux discours
politiques des provinces tout le monde
au fait le président aux premiers rôles
c'est ce que ça vaut nous on a besoin de
travail
françois hollande veut redonner du sens
à la parole présidentielle
donc je ne suis pas venu ici pour
laisser croire que dès l'élection
présidentielle tout sera possible
mais je suis venu ici pour dire que tout
sera engagée
tout sera fait pour que nous ayons la
clarté dans les objectifs et la
mobilisation des moyens à la veille du
sommet social françois hollande s'est
affiché aux côtés des ouvriers
il a promis un dialogue plus ouvert avec
les syndicats s'il est élu en mai
prochain
nicolas du poignant où j'allais quand
vendanges ou même à plus de cameyrac
d'ouvriers et il n'y a pas de mesures
concrètes
moi j'aimerais que françois hollande
françois bayrou aussi nous explique
comment on va relocaliser
si on ne met pas des écluses c'est à
dire des taxes douanières pour les
produits qui viennent de pays où le smic
est à 50 euros
il ne vole pas tous situés à ce tabou à
ce tabou du libre échange déloyal
dans l'union européenne bien sûr ils
sont prisonniers de traiter qui ruine la
france et le on fait des nouvelles sur
le vrai combat est celui là les
mondialistes d'à côté qui font semblant
de s'intéresser aux usines et ceux qui
comme moi et d'autres vont dire aux
français si vous voulez vraiment qu'on
conserve nos emplois il ya un moment il
faut plus jouer dans un jeu où les
autres triche
vous jouez pas aux cartes avec des
tricheurs qui après vienne vous racheter
un moment vous dites moi je veux bien la
concurrence avec des pays qui ont le
même standard de vie eu la même
protection de l'environnement alors ils
payeront des petites différences mais
d'accord la concurrence moi je suis pour
la concurrence
et je vous rappelle que l'europe elle
s'est fondée avec le général de gaulle
et adenauer avec la préférence
communautaire et que cette préférence
communautaire c'est ce qu'a permis de
construire leur dû pour aujourd'hui
c'est ce que vous préconisez la
préférence communautaire
le texto nisme quelque part tout cela ça
ne vous rapproche pas un peu d des idées
de marine le pen et du front national
éternelle question vous pourriez me dire
vous êtes devenu socialiste avec
montebourg
mais vous me dites à vos ressent d un
front national ça veut dire que quelque
part en france on fait croire aux
français qu'il y a que marine le pen qui
défend l'industrie l'emploi la france et
moi je considère le rock il y a le
retour au franc
oui je suis rentré connaissent pas la
région ravis que madame le pen est
abandonné les thèses de son père sur
libéralisme effréné et et copier ce que
je défends des avec tous ces gâteaux que
ça nous entendre et faire du fromage ne
sont pas si éloignées des nôtres avec
philippe séguin est mort mais est ce que
vous voulez en fait que toute personne
qui défend l'industrie la france soient
obligés d'aller au front national
moi je suis gaulliste je défends un
modèle en du front national et je pense
que cinq millions de français qui
veulent défendre l'emploi ne soit pas
obligatoirement obligé d'aller voter
front national s'il ne partage pas les
idées du front national
moi on va poser la question à l'envers
qu'est ce qui vous différencie du front
national sur ces conditions est-ce que
vous m'avez entendu
lisons faire des étrangers en france un
bouc émissaire
donc c'est l'émigration sur
l'immigration musulmane dans votre
prochain événement mais attendez faire
des affiches où je mets des minarets sur
mes affiches
est ce que vous m'avez vu année en
russie dire que poutine était faisait
quelque chose de très bien qu'il fallait
dérembourser les vg rétablir la peine de
mort je suis un gaulliste républicain je
suis ravi que nos idées protectionnistes
triomphe dans l'opinion parce que nous
sommes majoritaires en france mais il ya
des différences et les français doivent
avoir le choix il doit voter pour un
protectionnisme intelligent comme le
mien comme un modèle de société
je dirais ouvert avec des frontières
bien sûr et puis ils ont le choix de
marine le pen
voilà quand même une réduction d'un oui
la population immigrée de 50% ses 15 ans
à rien oui je dis que la pays qui a
perdu un million d'emplois en dix ans
industriels ne peut pas accueillir 200
mille étrangers chaque année en plus
parce que je dis pas ce que je vis dans
la banlieue et je dis que ce sont les
enfants français français de toutes les
couleurs de toutes les confessions qui
sont au chômage aujourd'hui et je
n'accepte pas que le medef que certains
patrons indélicats fasse venir des
ingénieurs qualifiés d'autres pays alors
que nos ingénieurs sont au chômage à 49
ans alors que nos enfants dans les
quartiers sont ont un taux de chômage de
40 % ne remplit pas forcément les
fonctions d'un jeune vieille a beaucoup
de beaucoup d'enfants dans le quartier
qui sont ingénieurs médecins avocats qui
ont fait de longues études leurs parents
se sont saignés ils ont leurs grades du
moulin serait-ce un psy c'est très
simple c'est qu'on fait venir des gens
qu'on paye deux fois moins qu'on met
dans des ghettos et d'ailleurs je
romains sont les défenseurs des sans
papiers qui sont complices du medef dans
cette affaire donc l'extrême gauche qui
soit disant défend les travailleurs
immigrés feraient mieux défendre les
français de toutes les couleurs de tous
les quartiers autre que vous avez montré
votre différence avec le front national
sont le sait bien on cherche toujours à
nous enfermer
parce qu'en fait la petite élite qui
dirige le pays qui l'a mené dans le mur
ne veut pas voir qu'il faut sortir de
l'euro met en place du protectionnisme
et enfin protéger nous
trier c'est tout on va passer à un autre
thème si vous voulez bien mardi toujours
nicolas sarkozy était lui aussi en
déplacement en ariège sur les terres du
président du sénat il présentait ses
voeux au monde agricole à cette occasion
et pour renouer avec un électorat
traditionnel il en a profité pour
fustiger les poids des règles
environnementales souvent trop lourde à
son côté nicolas sarkozy la préservation
de l'environnement ce n'est pas empêcher
quiconque de faire quoi que ce soit on
paralyse un territoire on empêche tout
le monde de prendre des initiatives
il faut absolument lever le pied
de ce point de vue ce que je dis sur
l'environnement je le dis également pour
la chasse là encore les chasseurs ne
sont pas les ennemis
c'est pas les adversaires de
l'environnement nicolas sarkozy avoue
l'avoir entendu et on l'année dernière
au salon de l'agriculture il l'avait dit
l'environnement ça commence à bien faire
mais cette électoraliste toussaint est
ce que moi je suis convaincu que les
français sont tordus de rire en
regardant ces images parce que qui a
multiplié les contraintes
environnementales sur les agriculteurs
depuis cinq ans avec le grenelle de
l'environnement c'est lui qui a accepté
les directives chasse de chasseurs qui
contraignent les chasseurs en france
c'est lui et donc eu c'est
extraordinaire samedi dans une terre
d'histoire de ce que voulait dire mais
c'est plus un bilan contradictoire
antique ça c'est une schizophrénie
politique qui est grotesque et puis j'ai
même pas besoin d'en parler tellement
c'est ridicule
ce qui ne sera pas au 2e tour nicolas
fait je fais mais il ne sera pas au
deuxième tour parce que les français ont
quand même du bon ciné candidats pour
cent dans sa mère icône du bon sens on
peut pas les prendre pour des abrutis et
des imbéciles nos concitoyens sont très
éveillée politiquement il regarde les
analyses on peut pas faire quelque chose
et dira le contraire
moi je respecte tout je respecte
quelqu'un qui est pas de mon avis mais
ce que je demande c'est de savoir qu'est
ce qu'ils proposent et on ne peut pas
savoir ce que nicolas sarkozy propose
pour la france puisqu'il a dit tout et
son contraire et je pense vraiment que
nos concitoyens pourront voter françois
bayrou françois hollande
autre moi même madame le pen etc mais je
pense qu'ils n'en peuvent plus de ce
double discours qui veulent savoir où on
va le président de la république doit
incarner un cap un projet cohérent et
s'y tenir pendant cinq ans sinon comment
voulez vous diriger la france
c'est pas possible alors on va encore
parler de nicolas sarkozy avec le sommet
social mercredi pour défier la crise il
l'avait baptisée sommet de crise nicolas
sarkozy a réuni pour quelques heures les
représentants syndicaux et patronaux à
l'elysée pour leur présenter un plan de
défense de l'emploi chiffré à 430
millions d'euros pour ne pas gâcher
l'ambiance il s'est montré plus discret
sur les sujets qui fâchent comme la tva
sociale
germain andrieu patronat et syndicats
réunis pendant près de quatre heures à
l'elysée à l'arrivée près d'un demi
milliard d'euros pour financer plusieurs
mesures d'urgence
l'objectif de nicolas sarkozy est très
clair enrayée au plus vite la spirale du
chômage
à trois mois de l'élection
présidentielle tout faire pour maintenir
une activité les salariés fut son
activité partielle tout faire pour
former les salariés pendant leur temps
libre
force est plutôt que de les licencier
nous avons également décidé un plan sans
précédent de formation des chômeurs très
éloignées de l'emploi
à la clé une enveloppe de 150 millions
d'euros pour la formation des chômeurs
au delà de deux ans d'inactivité
tous recevront une formation un emploi
ou un processus de socialisation
autre mesure clé 100 millions d'euros
pour la suppression des charges pour
tous les jeunes de moins de 26 ans dans
les tpe
un succès côté patronat une avancée
insuffisante pour les représentants
syndicaux
ces mesures la cvt les prend il ira même
s'ils vont pas aussi loin que ce que
nous avions souhaité ya des sujets qui
selon lui ne m'appelle pas négociations
avec les syndicats c'est lors qu'elle
est mauvaise mesures susceptibles d'être
prises à partir de là on ne négocie pas
je décide
ceci risque de se produire dans les
prochains jours aucun terrain d'entente
n'a été trouvé pour le moment sur les 35
heures et surtout sur la tva sociale
sur ce sujet comme sur celui du logement
ou encore la taxe sur les transactions
financières des décisions seront prises
avant la fin du mois après consultation
des parlementaires alors on va parler
bien entendu de toutes ces mesures mais
côté réaction le ps s'est empressé de
réagir avec vigueur c'est le cas de la
première secrétaire martine aubry qui
dénonce une opération médiatique
autre réaction celle du président du
sénat qui au cours de ses voeux s'en est
pris directement à nicolas sarkozy au
côté jean pierre bel
il a pensé comme une ajoutée associée à
la tva on pouvait peut-être fait un
convent certain nombre de choses il a
pensé que peut-être c'est la technique
de ce gouvernement en disant on va
augmenter de 4 et puis à la fin on
augmente de 2 balaÿ ruf
c'est l'histoire du fou qui se tape la
tête contre les murs et quand on lui
demande pourquoi il dit c'est bon car je
m'arrête
bon c'est un peu la technique
gouvernementale vous dites quoi nicolas
dupont aignan celso mais qu'à cause
d'une soirée bien sûr je rappelle aux
français que le gouvernement a donné 30
milliards d'euros aux banques en grèce
30 milliards d'euros et qu'on va
consacrer 400 millions pour indemniser
des chômeurs partiels et recruter 1000
emplois ou pôles emplois qui ont été
supprimés fait pas que je voudrais quand
même dire que c'est ces emplois ont été
supprimés au cours des deux dernières
années
je veux dire tout ça n'est pas à la
hauteur de lincent dit pour autant le ps
crime et propose rien et je crois que
vraiment nos concitoyens se disent mais
qu'est ce que concrètement peut faire il
ya d'autres mesures que la sortie de
l'euro et le protectionnisme
il ya des mesures pour nos muscles et
nos entreprises sociales vous êtes
plutôt coup a priori la taxe sur les
produits importés très bien mais la tva
sociale sur tous les produits qui va
toucher des retraités au moment où la
france s'enfonce dans un cycle de
récession c'est une pure folie
et je remarque d'ailleurs que les
agences de notation c'est intéressant de
lire sans en faire des boucs émissaires
comme certains en font des boucs
émissaires
qu'est ce qu'elles disent qu'est ce
qu'elle a dit standard d'une course elle
a dit les dirigeants européens ont
appuyé tellement sur le frein de
l'économie qu'ils sont en train de
s'engager dans une récession est native
l'enjeu c'est d'inciter nos entreprises
conduire en france et pour inciter nos
entreprises à produire de françois
bayrou d'accord bravo je suis ravi
qu'ils reprennent au slogan j'ai
toujours demandé mais il faut s'en
donner les moyens et pour produire en
france je propose par exemple que
l'impôt sur les sociétés comme dans
certains pays soient divisés par deux
pour les entreprises de moins de 500
salariés qui investissent les bénéfices
sur le sol français et ça mais ça il
faut déroger aux règles européennes ce
que françois bayrou ne fait pas et c'est
là où françois bayrou est entre deux
eaux moi je dis qu'il faut qu'un chef
d'entreprise en france se disent un jour
tiens il ya un nouveau gouvernement qui
a pris dix mesures qui m'incite à
produire en france et vous verrez que
les chefs d'entreprise ils volent
produire en france si on leur en donne
les moyens
c'est ça l'enjeu dans votre programme il
ya aussi la proposition de limiter le
salaire maximum à 30 6 fois le smic ça
fait combien ça en al'air manger à vos
calculs et ça fait à peu près 50 mille
euros j'estime que notamment dans les
entreprises publiques
je parle des entreprises publiques il
est indécent de voir des salaires
exorbitants
j'estime que les dirigeants des banques
et que le gouvernement aurait dû
rappeler aux banques aux dirigeants
banquiers que quand on a divisé par deux
la capitalisation d'une banque quand la
société générale on devrait diviser son
salaire par deux c'est indécent ce qui
se passe et là aussi rien toujours rien
c'est à dire ce sentiment que les
efforts c'est pour la masse du peuple
français et que eux il ya un très bon
livre qui vient de sortir du fait de la
pub la caste la casse nous l'oligarchie
des incapables
cette oligarchie française camille le
pays dans le mur et qui elle défend
toujours ses privilèges
ça suffit voilà pourquoi je dis qu'il
faut renationaliser edf et gdf les
fusionner qu'il faut le prendre une
participation chez total et qu'il faut
arrêter avec ces faits pour moins de
vols privés
la flambée des prix de l'essence louis
donc par le parti socialiste propose du
retour de la paix ppp flottant que c'est
un peu technique et c'est très bien donc
vous avez vous soyez d'accord avec les
parties sociales évidence lassus quand
l'attaquant le prix de l'essence
augmente la tva augmente à proportion et
les torts engrange les relaxes sur les
160 ans bien sûr
non il ya deux choses il ya la tei pépé
et à la télé à moi je suis bien sûr pour
qu'on a juste la tva qui a aucune raison
que l'état fasse du bon
sur l'augmentation du prix de l'essence
comme il n'y a aucune raison que total
est cassé la concurrence en france
aucune raison et autant je suis pour
développer la libre entreprise baisser
les charges sur les pme mais il faut
arrêter avec ces autres qui sont en
train de racketter le pouvoir d'achat
nos biens quand je pense que des f a
acheté pour 15 milliards d'euros
des centrales nucléaires pourri en
angleterre qui est la plus mauvaise
affaire faite par edf avec l'argent de
nos concitoyens qui paye durement leur
secteur électricité je dis ça suffit il
faut revenir mais vous plaisantez eux
edf est à 80% publics et les mesures du
gouvernement
si je comprends bien on laisse des
oligarques des gens en situation de
monopole faire n'importe quoi avec
l'argent des français parce que quand on
paye sa facture d'électricité
c'est quand même l'argent des français
il faut dans notre pays un président de
la république qui soit au dessus des
partis qui soit au dessus des intérêts
et qui gouverne en fonction de l'intérêt
supérieur de la nation dont parlait le
général de gaulle on va passer au
mercredi sous lui est bien nicolas
dupont aignan c'est la confusion au
sénat le texte sur la négation des
génocides sera-t-il voter l'examen aura
lieu lundi dans l'hémicycle la question
se pose alors que la commission des lois
a rejeté cette proposition et la juge
non conforme à la constitution toutes
les explications sur cet imbroglio avec
margot au brillant la commission des
lois a tranché réuni ce matin les 40
sénateurs rouge à une large majorité
pour la commission la proposition n'est
pas conforme à la constitution pourquoi
parce que le parlement comme l'a dit
fortement robert badinter n'est pas un
tribunal et parce que le parlement comme
l'a dit avec beaucoup de force pierre
nora n'a pas vocation à faire l'histoire
sur ce texte controversé les divisions
éclatent à droite et à gauche l'ump et
le ps appelle à voter pour mais c'était
sans compter les ré
essence de certains qui n'entendent pas
suivre les paires seulement au sein du
groupe socialiste
je ne sais pas sur l'accord de ram et
gelé exercerait comprendra donc que même
mon vote ira contre cette proposition
non ne donne pas de conseils comme ça
parce que ça sera désordre et moi je
n'aime pas ça je suis un homme libre de
gauche à droite le malaise est désormais
perceptible chez les défenseurs du texte
vous ne peut y avoir que consensus au
sein des socialistes sur un grave qu'un
génocide
pour ma part je préférerais qu'ils ne
participent pas au vote 1 et ne serait
ce que parce qu'effectivement ça
faciliterait le vote du texte
bien sûr bien sûr l'abstention hillis
dessus pour faire passer la proposition
de loi si après l'assemblée nationale
lundi le sénat vote pour elle sera
définitivement adopté
reste à savoir dans quelles conditions
on a appris ce vendredi que ankara la
turquie demande aux sénateurs de rejeter
ce texte est ce que cette loi vaut une
crise avec la turquie a de toute façon
je n'accepte pas qu'un pays étranger
dicté sa loi aux parlementaires et nous
confie la gérance on a eu en même temps
c'est vrai que moi j'ai voté la loi de
reconnaissance du génocide mais que j'ai
toujours une réticence à voter des lois
de pénalisation car même si je déteste
du fond de tout mon être
ceux qui nient les choses je pense que
ce n'est pas la loi qui doit dire
comment on doit penser sinon je vais pas
voter je me suis retenu que j'ai pas
participé au vote donc je suis très
partagé voyez je je comprends qu est-ce
qui doivent faire les sénateurs doivent
voter ou pas voter en conscience aux
tentations sa conscience face à des
parfums on ne peut pas avoir réponse à
tout on n'est pas des surhommes sur des
constats on est partagés parce qu'on n'a
pas envie que la turquie qui ne
reconnaît pas ce génocide qui et qui
donc on se la méprise la communauté
arménienne on a on ne peut pas accepter
qu'elle fasse pression et en même temps
ces lois mémorielles sont quand même
assez bizarre sans mal à l'aise quand
même avec avec cette affaire allait
mercredi toujours le premier ministre
hongrois viktor orban était sur la
sellette devant le parlement européen
il a nié la mise en place d'un
gym autoritaire et nationaliste dans son
pays par les parmi les lois qu'il a mise
en place le contrôle de la presse ou
encore le retour facilité officier ce
qui a inspiré cette attaque de daniel
cohn bendit
suivant la proposition de guy
verhofstadt envoyons par la commission
libertés publiques
une délégation pour avec l'article 7 dit
oui ou non
pourquoi s'en prit hongrie hop
pourquoi des intellectuels hopper
pourquoi de ma famille et des gens que
je connais juive en gris encore
aujourd'hui pourquoi l'esprit de notre
nouvelle constitution est une
constitution du nom glee passé qui fait
peu le droit d'avoir peur dans votre
pays monsieur ban
alors on ne parle pas là des mesures
liberticides mais le nationalisme le
proton est à la fois pour mes propres
non bien sûr et vous savez l'union
européenne sans frontières de la loi de
la jungle de la misère abouti à ces
réactions la sorbonne c'est le fruit de
l'union européenne comme en grèce il y a
des drapeaux maintenant avec la croix
gammée sur les drapeaux allemands comme
les allemands qui disent les pays du sud
ce sont des feignants ce que je veux
expliquer c'est que le retour des
nationalismes et la conséquence
mécanique de cette expo east de cette
fausse générosité qui aboutit à plonger
les peuples dans la misère et je pense
que les dirigeants européens quand il
aide les banques plutôt que les peuples
quand il plonge toute l'europe dans la
récession ferait mieux de regarder ce
qui est en train de se produire et je
crois dans pardonnez moi mais je crois
que justement parce que j'aime les
patries je suis contre les nationalismes
et que si vous continuez comme ça
l'europe sera feu et à sang et voilà
pourquoi il faut sortir de cette union
européenne malsaine et la reconstruire
sur des bases saines je vous cite
quelques mesures de monsieur robert fin
de l'indépendance de la banque centrale
une entrée dans l'euro protectionnisme
taxation des bruits étranges et et ça
vous prenez mais ça ça me choque pas du
tout au contraire
mais en revanche il ya des choses hors
ban que je n'aime pas notamment sur la
presse notamment sur cette minorité
donc vous voyez à dix questions
importantes ces mesures radicales
économiquement est ce qu'elle ne mène
pas de toute façon un régime autoritaire
puisqu'il faut étouffer les critiques
parce qu'il y en aura obeegadoo
aujourd'hui nous avons des régimes
autoritaires dans nos propres pays qui
est tous les critiques
donc je crois au contraire que si des
gens raisonnables et républicains comme
moi ne prenons pas
montebourg par exemple à gauche ne
prenons pas rapidement des mesures de
protection du peuple
ce seront des gens comme urban qui les
prendront parce que ces mesures de
protection elles sont inévitables parce
qu'il n'y a aucune raison par exemple
qu'on impose des taux d'intérêt à 7% en
italie alors même que monsieur draghi le
petit télégraphiste de goldman sachs
qu'on a mis à la tête de la banque
centrale prête aux banques à 1%
ça veut dire qu'on supprime des postes
d'infirmières de policiers dès que
d'enseignants en france en italie au
portugal qu'on condamne les peuples à la
misère pour nourrir des banques et les
copains et vous voulez après qu'ils
aient pas des retours de flamme
est-ce que l'union européenne l'histoire
de l'europe est ce que l'union
européenne a bien fait de sanctionner la
hongrie mais l'union européenne a tort
de sanctionner la hongrie sur ses
mesures économiques alors qu'elle
devrait plutôt sanctionner des mesures
de hongrie sur les droits de l'homme et
ces questions là juste pour faire et
activent leurs bios populiste on va dire
mais ce que vous ne fasse que vous
comprenez j'imagine c'est qu'un
continent européen qui défend les plus
riches qui asphyxie les peuples et qui
les conduit à la misère va alimenter des
réactions d'une violence inouïe
et c'est là où les dirigeants européens
et les petite oligarchie qui nous
gouvernent
moi je me bats ici ma candidature est là
prêt pour but justement d'offrir ce que
c'est un proposait ce que jean pierre
chevènement a essayé de proposer un
patriotisme tranquille patriotisme
protecteur c'est ça l'enjeu
vous pourriez vous retrouver avec jean
pierre chevènement notamment je serais
ravi qui soutient le candidat est
heureux qu'ils me soutiennent et
d'ailleurs troupes
comme il ya des socialistes de chez vous
pour des militants des cris ont dit on
va vous comme ils chanteront soutiennent
parce que l'enjeu c'est plus le clivage
droite gauche c'est le clivage entre les
mondialistes qui nous mène à la suite du
non c'est louis mais bien sûr mais bien
celle là président syrien sur ce sera ce
un match retour le match retour bien sûr
et je serais moi je ferai tout pour que
les français sachent que c'est un
référendum sur le oui ou le non est ce
que vous votez gallier ou est-ce que
vous voter pour des gens qui veulent
changer le système le corriger dans la
paix civile et dans la tolérance bien
sûr vous avez beaucoup parlé d'un homme
au cours de cette émission c'est
françois bayrou a passé pas aujourd'hui
ont rendu car aura plus que d'autres on
va en parler à nicolas dupont aignan il
appelle à la résistance
premier grand meeting de campagne donc
pour françois bayrou l'homme qui cessent
de grimper dans les sondages il était à
dunkerque l'occasion pour lui de parler
à nouveau de son thème fétiche le
produit français et d'appeler à la
résistance reportage thomas souliers et
betty lagière il peut être leur porte
parole
pour son premier meeting de campagne
françois bayrou n'a qu'un mot à la
bouche le peuple à dunkerque
le candidat à la présidentielle vient
chasser sur les terres du front national
et appelle à la résistance il y à un
désespoir en ce moment un désespoir
particulier du peuple les petits les
obscurs les sans grades
ce sont eux qui aujourd'hui ont besoin
qu'on parle à leur nom dans l'élection
présidentielle de la république
française en discours offensif pour
convaincre les indécis ceux tentés par
la prothèse père dans la salle étant
mais aussi beaucoup de curieux venus
écouter le quatrième homme des sondages
j'ai pensé que c'était un vrai discours
de président
et globalement eux
il a vraiment pas manier la langue de
bois il a le tort de croire qu'il va
gagner parce qu'il a raison voilà c'est
pas le bon discours il faut il ya
discours et professeurs c'est pas comme
ça qu'on gagne je voter pour sarkozy aux
dernières élections
mais je crois que là je suis revenu
votre et bayrou et et balle au premier
tour et oui le deuxième aussi dans cette
campagne françois bayrou poursuit sa
stratégie se poser en alternative la
seule au duel ps ump
ils ont chois effectivement d'autres
choses que ces deux candidats qui sont
les candidats qui se renvoient la balle
depuis un certain nombre d'années
vont-ils choisir effectivement peut-être
une pensée différente une transgression
que j'appelle raisonnable qui est celle
de françois bayrou je crois que c'est
important aussi de le dire y compris
dans ses terres
crédité jusqu'à 15 % dans les sondages
françois bayrou poursuit son ascension
gravir les sommets avec un seul objectif
en tête accéder cette fois ci au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle
nicolas dupont aignan françois bayrou
c'est le quatrième homme de cette
élection et ne cesse de monter dans les
sondages
est-ce qu'il peut aller plus loin si il
va plus loin aussi dans son revirement
intellectuelle s'il s'agit simplement de
faire acheter français et faire un peu
ce un produit c'est jacques chirac en 95
vraiment jeune anglais la fracture
sociale etc
ça veut dire françois bayrou a compris
le désespoir des français mais si il
reste dans sa contradiction qui est de
demander cela mais en même temps d'être
d'accord avec l'om c'est avec l'union
européenne
avec cette ouverture à tous vents une
fois au pouvoir il fera comme les autres
il n'aura pas de résultat moi je me
souviens des discours de nicolas sarkozy
qui m'avait séduit entre les deux tours
notamment sur l'euro dans les ardennes
très beau discours de henri guaino
nicolas sarkozy dans les ardennes
et puis une fois élu il est allé signer
lisbonne s'est couché devant l'allemagne
il s'est couché devant monsieur barroso
monsieur trichet donc le problème de son
ce ne sont pas les discours ce sont les
actes et moi j'attends justement de la
campagne présidentielle et demain
candidature de dire à tous les candidats
vous faites pas semblant et moi j'avais
proposé de vraies mesures
protectionnistes alors sortie de l'euro
voilà le vrai enjeu françois bayrou ne
cesse de proclamer qu'il veut un
gouvernement ou en tout cas un esprit
d'union nationale s'il vous appelle dans
ce gouvernement vous y allez d'abord
françois bayrou n'est pas encore élu je
suis dans une hypothèse où je n'en sais
rien je ne suis pas là pour ça moi mon
seul objectif c'est de montrer aux
français qu'une autre politique est
possible c'est de montrer aux français
qui sont pas condamnés à souffrir dans
cette politique je dirais de laval 1935
c'est à dire toujours plus de souffrance
pour les peuples toujours plus de
privilèges pour les autres ça ça peut
pas durer et d'avoir des solutions
la thèse françois bayrou marine le pen
qui ne cesse de monter qui est à la une
de cette semaine du magazine l'express
et pourquoi pas eux
pourquoi est ce qu'à votre avis ni
françois hollande ni nicolas sarkozy ne
peuvent être au deuxième tour côté jeu
avant l'express donc je suis content que
l'équipe va demander des droits d'auteur
j'ai dit ni l'un ni l'autre ne seront
jours je me dis qu à east peace
et ne veulent plus traire siamois qui en
fait défendent la même politique qui
acceptent les mêmes contraintes et les
mêmes règles du jeu et qui en même temps
font semblant de s'opposer et qui sont
eux mêmes responsables
en fait depuis 1981 de cette dérive
référencez votre page mais attention si
c'est pour avoir fausse alternative avec
françois bayrou ou une alternative est
excessive avec marine le pen c'est pas
bon non plus voilà pourquoi je pense que
mon alternative est plus crédible même
si je suis plus petit nicolas dupont
aignan a terminé cette émission avec
l'annoncé vendredi de la mort de quatre
soldats français en afghanistan nicolas
sarkozy a laissé entendre que l'on
pourrait accélérer le retrait c'est ce
qu'il faut faire
se retirer quand des soldats français
meurent
on n'entre pas dans des luttes
politiques
on salue leur mémoire mais moi je veux
simplement dire
reprenez tous mes écrits quand nicolas
sarkozy a décidé d'envoyer des troupes
j'ai tiré la sonnette d'alarmé j'étais
l'un des sols et quand obama a décidé de
rapatrier les troupes
j'ai écrit il faut les rapatrier au plus
vite car la condition de leur sécurité
n'est pas assurée je suis membre de la
commission de la défense à l'assemblée
nationale et la voilà on m'a ri au nez
on m'a ri au nez en disant que je ne
comprenais rien et aujourd'hui parce que
les élections approchent de voix le
président de la république le dire tant
mieux mais moi je me mets à la place des
familles des soldats
ça c'est jeune voilà merci à nicolas
dupont aignan d'avoir participé à cette
émission avec nous et nous nous
retrouvons michael la semaine prochaine
merci